absolutely heartbroken okay as I know
you are I've been watching the coverage
unfolds and as you may know I was there
myself in March this year my capacity as
a doctor we were training other doctors
who were fearing the worst they were
fearing that they didn't know how to
manage mass casualty triage of the sort
of scale that we're now seeing they were
worried about their hospitals and
workplaces being bombed and we saw
firsthand after you know being in a
bunker ourselves we saw firsthand just
what they were doing to other Medics
what they were doing
to civilians and we also met families
that showed us that there is nothing
that Russia wouldn't do to gain power
and to see
hospitals targeted Mass Graves it is it
is Beggar's belief that this is
happening and I think we're all
absolutely heartbroken
what was the mood like when you were
there
everyone was so frightened okay
we had doctors that we were training we
trained 250 doctors who were in tears
saying I'm an eye specialist I'm a
psychiatrist I don't know what I'm going
to do with all of the dead bodies
they were fearing
chemical weapons attacks because they
were seeing what was happening in the
Syrian Playbook playing out so
um people being held hostage in
hospitals and in areas then starved of
food and then brought to the surface of
where they were hiding in order to
search for food and then the potential
of chemical weapons attacks so there was
a deep fear a deep distress and a deep
sense of how has this happened
I know that you have um one of the
reasons you want to come and talk to us
today is about the rising concerns about
mental health here in the UK and when we
see these images of course and we worry
about the people who basically live in
Europe and they're having to live under
these conditions must have an impact on
people here it does we're all human
aren't we we all watch those images and
we think about our own children we think
about our own families and while there
myself and my medical team actually
rescued a family who had been shot at
close range and the children had had
bits of their body parts blown up their
grandmother had been murdered before
their very eyes and We rescued them and
took them to Poland my mum's polish
their their mother that was shot was
just like my mother and it's absolutely
heartbreaking and the British people are
are so wonderful so kind-hearted so
open-hearted and what they've done to
support ukrainians and open their homes
has been amazing um but just to just to
watch it play out I don't think there's
anybody that doesn't feel a sense of
deep distress and yes it will be having
an impact on people's mental health
along with everything else that they're
that they're having to deal with another
concern a lot of people have is the cost
of living crisis we're hearing from the
government they still haven't decided
whether benefits will increase with
inflation or not
it absolutely has to do like benefits
have to increase with inflation we
shouldn't see those on the lowest
incomes and those with disabilities
worse off but okay I still work on the
NHS front line and in a e we see people
who have attempted to take their own
lives with the reason being doctor I
don't know how to feed my family I don't
know how to heat my home we're seeing
toddlers coming in with Burns and we're
not even in in deep winter yet okay
we're seeing people coming in with Burns
because they have used old electric
heaters we're seeing you know toddlers
coming in with burns from burst water
bottles because their parents don't know
how to heat the house and they're using
old water bottles to take them to bed
with them and they burst this is the
reality and it's absolutely
heartbreaking and something has to be
done and while the government are sort
of playing games and are in all this
sort of turmoil you know Grant shaps
wants to be caretaker prime minister
Boris Johnson is planning his combat
Nadine Doris is calling for general
election people are really struggling
the people that we see in our
constituency surgeries the people that I
see in my hospital they want to know why
their child who has been in in a mental
health crisis for 79 hours is still in a
e they want to know why they're referral
I mean one million adults have been
referred for mental health treatment
that has been closed they haven't even
had the support and it's costing the
economy 117 billion pounds and and
people are really struggling and it's
not a game it's it's real life people
are choosing between Heating and eating
Nicholas sturgeon has she's at her s p
conference in Aberdeen she says that she
detests the Tories in everything they
stand for you
I don't detest anybody what I do think
is we have an omni shambles of a
government but what do you think about
that terminology that we're doing it
doesn't help does it it's not wording
that I would choose to use it's I think
she should be focusing on
on her broken Health Services on on um
on the attainment Gap in Scotland on the
fact that there are more children now
plunged into poverty than ever I think
she should be focusing her conference
speech on that rather than using using
that sort of terminology and I and I
think
um ultimately the Scottish people
deserve better than this than the Nicola
sturgeon should Connor Burns get a
Knighthood
there has to be an absolute full
investigation into what's happened and
he should not receive a Knighthood until
the outcome of that is very clear
and Tom Watson should he receive one
he's not up for a Knighthood he's up for
repairage forgive me appearance
absolutely oh should you get that then I
think he should
um I had the honor of having him as my
boss actually for three years while I
was the shadow Minister for sport he was
he was really good to work with he was
very supportive and um ultimately it's
very common for MPS to to end up in the
House of Lords many MPS who finish up
with that controversy as you know I mean
um suggestions that he's insulting the
families of those that were caught up in
an investigation
um where one person had committed
suicide because they felt that they
couldn't cope with the allegations
against them which were proved unfounded
lady Britain says absolutely under no
circumstances should this go ahead why
do you think otherwise
I think you'd have to ask Tom Watson the
details of it what you think I mean it
would be a labor peer wouldn't he yeah
he'd be a labor peer I personally think
that care has made a decision as to who
gets a period she's chosen Tom Watson
for very good reasons and I think that
it's right that Tom does go to the Lords
but on the details of everything you'd
have to speak to Tom about that it's
good to talk to you as always thank you
thank you thank you very much